"Construir una recta perpendicular a la recta
dada." Bueno, si tomamos dos puntos arbitrarios en
esta recta y construimos una recta que sea siempre
equidistante a esos dos puntos, entonces esa recta
será perpendicular; en realidad sería la bisectriz
perpendicular del segmento formado por esos dos
puntos. Ahora, no nos piden la bisectriz de un
segmento, nos piden una recta perpendicular, así
que hagámosla. Primero, utilizamos el compás para
dibujar un círculo, y vamos a tomar un punto por
aquí, podemos ajustar el radio de ser necesario
pero lo dejaré así. Ahora vamos a dibujar otro
círculo, y pongamos su centro en donde se
interseca el primer círculo con la recta, y vamos
a ajustar el radio de tal forma que se superponga
con el primer centro. Podemos observar que los dos
puntos en donde se intersecan estos dos círculos
son equidistantes a cada uno de estos centros que
acabamos de construir. Así que dibujemos una
recta que conecte esos dos puntos y esa recta
será perpendicular a nuestra recta dada.
Comprobemos nuestra respuesta. Estamos bien.